24 year old Daniel penny is Led in
handcuffs from a police station in lower
Manhattan and taken to New York Criminal
Court to face second-degree manslaughter
charges for causing the death of a
homeless man Jordan Neely Daniel Penny
surrendered at the fifth Precinct at the
request of the New York County District
Attorney's office
so voluntarily and with the sort of
dignity and integrity that is
characteristic
of his history of service
to this Grateful Nation
the former Marines lawyers claim he
stepped in to protect himself
and suffered from mental mental illness
became aggressive they say he never
meant to kill him on Friday Neely's
family roundly rejected that argument in
a press conference so should Daniel
Penny be charged with manslaughter
absolutely
because he acted with indifference
he didn't care about Jordan he cared
about himself
and we can't let that stand
the arrest comes nearly two weeks after
the incident occurred spurring
demonstrations over what protesters
described as vigilante justice they say
that New York officials failed nearly
who was known as a street performer and
had multiple run-ins with police and
Social Service organizations
they also say penny should have been
immediately charged but legal experts
say it could be a difficult case to
prove the defendant has rights
especially in the criminal justice
system and the defendant will advance
defenses the defense of justification
the defense of self-defense or the
defense of others that the force the
defendant used was legally Justified and
probably also that he did not intend to
cause the death of uh the decedent penny
did not enter a plea and was released on
July Kristen salumi Al Jazeera New York